في وقت فيه اهالي غزه بامس الحاجه الى
المساعده تتعرض وكاله الانروا المصدر
الوحيد للاغاثه لحمله غير
مس القضيه بدات عندما زعمت اسرائيل مشاركه
ا موظفا لدى الانر في هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر واعلنت نيتها انهاء اي نشاطات
للوكاله وذلك ما دفع دولا منحه عده مثل
الولايات المتحده والمانيا وبريطانيا
وكندا لقطع تمويلها
فورا اللافت في هذه القضيه سرعه رد فعل
هذه الدول بوقف التمويل رغم تعهد الامم
المتحده بفتح تحقيق وفصل اي موظف تثبت
مشاركته في اعمال
مسلحه
كما كان لافتا ايضا حدوثها بعد ساعات من
قرار محكمه العدل الدوليه الزام اسرائيل
السماح بمرور المساعدات الانسانيه لسكان
غزه مجموع التمويل الضائع وصل حتى الان
الى نحو 60% من ميزانيه الوكاله و هذا
الامر الخطير يهدد من قطاع شريان الحياه
عن سكان القطاع الذين يعيشون اساسا ظروفا
قاسيه لا تحتمل مين اللي بدش يدعمها يعني
تدعمنا حرام عليهم يقفوا معانا خلي النار
تدعمنا وتعطينا وتدعمنا لكن دو عده كاسبان
وايرلندا والنرويج اكدت مواصله دعمها
للاناره فيما استنكرت اطراف عده تجاهل
الدول التي اوقفت التمويل استهداف اسرائيل
لمدارس ومراكز الانر وقتل اكثر من 100 من
موظفيها وهو اكبر عدد من القتلى يسجل في
صفوف موظفي الامم المتحده في حرب
واحده ولفهم العلاقه بين اسرائيل والانروا
بشكل اوضح من الضروري العوده الى سبب
تاسيس هذه الوكاله الذي جار بعد النكبه
بقرار من الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
وهو اداره شؤون اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
حين عودتهم الى ديارهم ما يعني ان القانون
الدولي يضمن لهؤلاء اللاجئين حق العوده
الى ارضهم وهو امر قد لا يعجب
اسرائيل